what makes you an artist is that you
wake up in the morning and you have this
creative energy to produce
dubai has become a magnet for the most
eclectic and talented creative minds
if i could sum it up in one word i would
say potential
i'm moana davis i'm daniel rada
together we are architects and
photographers
our approach is to play with
perspectives and geometry within an
urban landscape and as architects we
travel the world exploring unseen
aspects of buildings so we can tell
stories to the image
we are on a journey to meet with other
like-minded and inspiring creatives in
dubai
[Music]
we are exploring dubai's foremost art
hub altacal avenue bringing together
established gallery excavations
workshops and studios where grassroots
artists are given the tools to begin
creating to learn how it came to be we
meet with the director of alsacar avenue
welcome i'm originally from lithuania i
studied in the states i was in france
and then the last stop was dubai
well i'm looking forward for us to kind
of walk around and introduce it to the
creative community of dubai
australian is comprised of 91 different
warehouses it used to be an old marble
factory that belonged to a circle family
i wanted to make a meaningful
contribution to arts and culture for me
circle avenue is about bringing the
community closer to arts and culture
through a variety of art forms and
experiences
the art scene is just taking its steps
and just starting to create itself it's
so important that there is someone that
believes in a young artist
there is an incredible homegrown
artistic community here and really
really talented individuals that are
involved in creating the history and and
really producing fantastic work that's
now becoming more recognized
internationally
hi we saw the worship from outside and
we're curious about what you guys do
we're here doing sneaker customization
how does it feel to be working in this
space with all this art around you it's
really good it's inspiring for us as
artists because once you arrive in dubai
it feels like everything is super
polished once you get to know the
creative scene you realize that you can
do whatever you want you just need to
find the right place to do it to date we
worked with almost 20 artists from all
over the world commissioning them to
produce ephemeral work step by step we
are building the infrastructure for the
arts not only for the city of dubai but
for the uae and and the region in the
past we produced about 3 000 cultural
events open and free to the public
anything from music to film screening to
an exhibition and as a result we saw a
rise in our community we had the
pleasure to meet with local artists
sheikha al-masru who was exhibiting her
intriguing devi works expansion
extension jake is challenging the
perception of the types of eyework one
might expect to find coming out of dubai
i always tend to say this when you're
comfortable you tend to make boring
works and i like to push myself in this
kind of uncomfortable corner so these
come in metal sheets i see this material
and i really want to change their
physical properties you start you know
squeezing it changing its norms it's
funny how you use the word squeeze when
you're speaking about metal which is
another squeezable material so that's
amazing
next we visit jpnf collection a private
museum bringing decades of experience
artistic prowess to a circle avenue
we're very proud of our space it is
really designed with abstract art in
mind every decision an artist makes
affects the results of their work so
whether it is the shape of the canvas
the size of their brush everything has a
thought behind it absolutely we cannot
relate also we have these super simple
images but at the same time you have a
lot of work done before
it's so important to constantly embrace
the history the context and local
elements before we are able to create a
story of our own these local artists are
proud of where they have come from and
clearly see where they are going
to be able to meet with these inspiring
artists felt like we were discovering
the beginning of something special in
artistic scene
when it comes to creative talent it's so
important to create a platform and the
springboard for their work to be shown
it's this access to opportunity and
potential to realize anything that you
set out to do
and i think a city like dubai allows you
to do that
[Music]
you